je veux dire je suis conscient que le
mal a confié à lecteurs l'asie laissant
le soin aux yeux tant en commun briguer
de nouveau renier une anna paule de sa
baisse de seulement la région le concept
est encore compris que les sociétés ont
besoin de récits de loi pour s'émouvoir
en simple il faut parfois c'est le mal
que je vais faire coexister dire en gare
et des ressentis différents kalemie mois
sur son rendement par toi ou
conflictuelles et c'est ce que vous avez
réussi à faire beaucoup
dans la formule vivent 30 que la rumeur
de lait frais bien à passer une première
réalisation
monsieur monsieur ban l'interdisait et
le récent dit qu'une corporation sera
chaud la première cérémonie ressources
la seconde les cellules ans et la
troisième c'est en ouvrir les voies
nouvelles comme le souhaitait le seul
état l'équipe les intervenants ont
retracé éléphants dégénéra tracé avant
vous l'avez produits les gens qu'ont
vécu les gens m'ont ému et fait rire
quand on construit
qu'ont ils fait pour l'essentiel ils ont
construit lui lier et coria nul à paris
cominar ou le liban les airs ils ont
construit la société nous n'aime pas
l'elysée
ensemble ils seront également participé
à l'aîné avance et inti navy dans
l'économie réunionnaise a toujours été
et le niveau d'emploi date idée de
ressources et nos recettes
trois cent cinquante ans tout se perd
autrefois évoqué aujourd'hui les mamans
si le tour de que nous et à ce que toute
la vie est faite du désir la vie sociale
la vie et lui me johanne fournier la vie
et c'est toute cette vieille bique dans
le désir
derrière ce bel fois le général les
monarchies
shi des quatre ans par l'europe de
verser pour le gentil et l'instructeur
du train comprendra cinq des bossons
chevaux à écouter en classe 38 des
chocolats partie de la cour vola de
10,14 capeline un peu les six dans les
mots en erdre et a recommandé une
seconde fois au monde le sache
parfois il y avait toujours la misère
des gens cherchant leur art les ans tu
as pris ma chance en lourd la fontaine
où il a fait l'insalubrité à
saint-claude et notre espace des lions
villes partagent les moustiques et il y
avait foule et leur foi l'amour et
autres délices les enfants tout ce que
nous avons pour nous la ville la vie on
était ensuite par les désirs et
jean-pierre il par les idées les autres
indésirables
et d'avoir été question là ça fait bien
de jeu écoutez et la mélodie du passé se
détendit aujourd'hui comme une berceuse
de grammaire ou le parent pauvre les
échos à grasse et torres a réalisé
président était en tout cas cette
affaire et a chargé les rations il faut
que la génération change et en sort le
monde allant de chacun d'entre nous a
apporté les îles du grand serveur n'est
nous n'est pas seulement la matière elle
avait le disent pas et c'est propre
musique est inexistant mais désire
intelligence de l'ampli mes désirs vos
rangs parole pour construire déshérence
et ceux de nous seuls à coller les
jeunes représentant le conseil général
des jeunes
c'est nu sans chichis juste jeu
[Applaudissements]